let me tell you about the greatest
stand-in in esports history he's trapped
in at the car he's gonna need help he's
gonna need bailing out oh burning alive
and jks is swinging as well that's the
pistol the
[Applause]
falls off and he falls the wrong way so
was not to be spawned into legacy
beaches waited out but jks that is
unbelievable
what can this man not do for faze let me
tell you about the guy who wasn't even
supposed to be at one of the biggest
tournaments of the year and won anyway
jks
the stand-in win map two for them let me
tell you about the guy who struggled for
years almost missed his shot and finally
won it all when no one believed in him
so many gambles on this team but it's
finally paid off the intel extreme
masters council champions phase clan in
hey folks before we get in the video you
might have noticed that this is the very
first episode of our brand new show
worth if you like what you're seeing
then please sub to the channel and turn
on notifications because it really does
help and we hope you enjoy the show
anyway nobody expected jks to pop off at
esl one kind of video 2022 mostly
because he wasn't even supposed to be at
the tournament in the first place jks is
esports greatest stand-in and in order
to understand how he got there we need
to understand where he came from first
see jks has pretty much been playing
counter-strike since he was old enough
to hold a mouse he's been competing for
almost his entire life back then
obviously there was a lot less exposure
and less tournaments and stuff like that
in 1.6 so for me especially because i
was a kid it was more just like kind of
being better than everyone else around
me kind of thing like that's how i found
the fun in it like the competitiveness
it wasn't really anything like you know
i want to grow up and play overseas or
anything like that i kind of just wanted
to be better than everyone else that i
knew as he grew up jks quickly became
one of australia's number one cs go
talents the problem was that australia
only really had one internationally
competitive roster and they weren't
exactly on top of the world and if they
try and come for him well they're in
headshot range and there's the first one
going down kenny there to support havoc
is now gone and jks is gonna be alone
here looking for a pick off and he's
only gonna get the one on vox and later
renegades jks grew into a serious
international threat he was easily the
best player in australia with incredible
skills and an ability to clutch that
rivaled some of the best players in the
world and out of peeking from a jungle
here he can't get the shot and jks gets
it that might have been it here
disturbing a one on two to clutch for
his team to keep their hopes alive he's
got two hp on jks havoc on 19. he
actually hits it through the box but jks
connects and that is box advancing
through into the winners bracket winning
16-11 over 3d max nico ready and waiting
he like shots him but he doesn't go down
sponge with the double and he's going to
come in for a little bit more here pimp
goes down there it is fox seminar did he
make the next major and global offensive
16-13 and look at that celebration
can't take his pick anything up here
good damage there the [__] he finishes
him off this position is actually really
good for jks you could spray down a
couple more players there's the second
one and the third one excellent stuff
from jks and then the remaining two are
really weak here this guy could be
working on a massive clutch gets the
next kill it's just adren left now for
liquid working on the ace jks
has to
bottom unbelievable stuff this guy's so
hot unfortunately despite jks's
incredible talent the aussies just
couldn't win anything and mousesports
coming now into the overtime absolutely
destroying renegades it's just three
left for the ct side and maybe the dream
is over though as a drops the bomb
carrier just one player alive jks here
in the connector and he goes down mouse
sports 19 15.
somebody is a lot the high ground going
to do this for his team jks finally gets
attacked but he can't get the round and
it will be tyloo
16 to 10 over renegades sonny surely
will have the jump on this you still
always convince somebody's in ct he's
got a moonwalk straight into the end of
the match
16 to four that was all mousesports it
got so bad that by the end of 2018 jks
was almost ready to call it quits i
think we had some up and down results
but i wasn't really sure if i wanted to
keep playing or not um i was actually
like really questioning it towards the
end uh because we did get to go home for
one of these events and
then i remember how nice it is being at
home and having friends at home and
stuff like that and just
uh
like just pretty much just everything at
home and it made me miss it and i was
really questioning whether or not i
wanted to play and then i think i had a
really good event pro league at the end
of 2018 and from there on founders had
that mindset where like i need to just
start playing really well i need to like
play professionally i need to do
everything right you know i should put
everything into it just so
i'm not wasting my time overseas when i
can't be at home jks rolled up his
sleeves and got to work here it is by
triple with the awp he's got a peek out
misses the first shot that's not going
to be good enough there's no second shot
really to be fired all connected as
gratis faction again
we love it when he is going for these
crazy plays off the open again he's
setting up his team leads coming in from
the side there from ct and that's it
renegades win by time
gratis faction again james jake in the
grass faction one frag one click of the
mouse and this could be it legend status
for renegades they're doing it 2019 went
pretty well for jks he made the hltv top
20 for the first time in his career
renegades got signed 100 thieves and it
looked like he was finally going to hit
the big time but then in spring 2020
covet hit cs go's so-called online era
was hard on everyone but for a lineup of
australians playing for a north american
org going up against teams based in
europe it was brutal at the time
we were obviously had to live overseas
stay overseas and play online cs and
like none of us really like online cs
everyone likes lance yes everyone likes
the crowd and stuff like that
especially in north america is awful
because you play the same teams over and
over and over again like every week so
it wasn't very fun in that aspect but
definitely sucks that we had to cut it
short because of that 100 fees obviously
had to drop us because of kobe
unfortunately
100 thieves is exiting cs go
i think the most glaring issue that our
organization has faced has been coveted
so jks jumped ship he couldn't just sit
around doing nothing which is why he
joined complexity but things only got
worse from there
shiro he's ready for it he does start
off with the first no refraction to back
him up this is beautiful from gambit
textbook and config he's having to push
through the flames look how much damage
he's chased
he may get this kill on just your right
convict you are not supposed to miss
those
oh and he gets knifed that round is the
most hard brilliant i have seen in the
last eight hours of my life complexity's
results were so abysmal that just over a
year after jks joined the roster they
disbanded which left his future
prospects looking dim i was kind of
relieved in a way you know i didn't
really want to play in that team anymore
i don't think the lineup was really
working and the atmosphere was really
bad and just being straight up honest i
think it was kind of a relief at that
point
of course it was a little bit scary
because
i didn't have the best performance on
that team and of course other teams are
going to be looking at your previous
performance over the last couple months
or something like that
so it didn't really look that positive
for me at this point it wasn't clear
what came next for jks while nobody
seriously doubted his talent his time on
complexity didn't do him any favors jks
wasn't exactly a top prospect he sat on
the bench for months from november until
well into the new year jks didn't play a
single game of professional
counter-strike his career wasn't just on
pause
it looked like it was kind of over
and then out of nowhere
fate intervened
around like february 10th i think twists
messaged me on steam i haven't touched
cs in about two months so i was kind of
reluctant to play and obviously i told
him that because you know i didn't want
to lie to show up
but uh i think he really pushed for me
to play for the team
i really had to
convince him that jks was still the best
option and i didn't care that he didn't
play the game for two months and i
actually felt like his time on
complexity was
uh inaccurate representation of what he
can do as a player
and uh i think the system that
complexity had which is bad for him so i
really wanted to have i wanted him to
have a chance in our team as soon as
they said that they did actually want to
select me
that night i think i
booked a hotel in the city of copenhagen
and then i
asked australia if i could play at that
place and
i stayed there for maybe three or four
days playing like 12 hours of cs a day
just so i can get back to form a little
bit this was an extremely high stakes
offer for jks it was a chance to prove
himself sure but it was also a chance to
fall even flatter i mean it was
definitely was a really rusted period
and i was
about if i should play on it because i
didn't want to make things look worse
but at that point it's kind of just like
what i have to lose i may as well play
and
if i play like [__] it is what it is all
jks wanted was to prove that he deserved
a spot on a top tier roster to prove
that he was more than just his year of
struggles but the pressure was on he
even told hltv that he wasn't so much
playing to win as he was playing not to
lose i kind of just want to make sure
that we make it as far as we possibly
can before robs comes back because i
don't really want to be the reason to
blame you know like the reason why these
guys drop out of the tournament saying
if we lose or something like that but
the thing is
faze did win and not despite jks but
because of him we'll see if frozen gets
drawn over the lip of this ledge
jks turns attention gets the first one
now it's all about finishing off dexter
31 hp this would be a big round for face
to just push over the line but it needs
to be jks and there's his round there's
his moment especially with the smoke
having just gone out as well they use
their second oh
jk yes who lights them up and sticks
their heads on spears but what it does
is delay a little bit jks puts a deed
together dude phase and eagles that's
what they're
another from jks three kills in this one
faze blew through the play in stage with
two quick wins over sprout and mouse and
that's where jks's story should have
ended rops was back for the group stage
which meant that jks was back to the
bench after a solid but quiet
performance but then fate intervened
once again after the group stage faze's
long time rifler rain tested positive
for kovit so they had to call jks back
in for the big time playoffs this was
going to be jks's biggest test
all eyes were on him because he could
have been the reason for an early exit
for faves
instead he delivered he's trapped in at
the car he's gonna need help he's gonna
need bailing out oh burning alive and
jks is swinging as well that's the
pistol for faze clan flash is coming in
and he can't afford to follow up oh
he's entry like ray he's lurked like
rob's now expected to clutch like brokey
and it's not going to happen time eludes
him on this one just exits is the name
of the game and oh he's gonna get them
all at least with the help of jks's
truly unbelievable stand in play faze
shredded gambit and heroic two of the
best teams in the world with back to
back two o's jks was in the grand finals
of a tournament he wasn't even supposed
to be at with one of the best teams in
the world on his side at this point jks
had accomplished more than anyone could
have asked of him he didn't just not
lose he helped take faze all the way to
the grand finals they could have lost to
g2 and placed second and people still
would have sung jks's praises
but that's not what happened
for maybe the first time in his career
jks was facing little to no pressure to
perform see for years of playing on
australian lineups jks was always the
star he was always the guy who had to
pop off every game the guy who always
had to carry but that's not what playing
on faves was like
some of the best players in the world
were on his side of the server brokey
was opting robs and twists were vying
for the role of star rifler and kerrigan
was calling the shots jks made an
incredible cinderella run to get here
but the pressure wasn't exclusively on
him to take it all the way so jks had
almost nothing to lose
and he played like it
fast paced towards banana the play has
been called hunter's going to turn that
corner jks has got him huddled behind
another flashbang from kerrigan faze
stole map one but map two mirage was an
endless bloodbath the two teams
struggled to close it out for almost 60
rounds until jks came up huge
he's got him back in the corner he's
spotted out and this is absolutely
doable now he's got all the utility all
the play that he needs flash and a nade
as well as the defuse kit
jumping across he'll start making noise
this position's given up but alexa b has
been very disciplined in this situation
quick tap falls off and he falls the
wrong way so as not to be spotted i like
cb just wait till now but jks has it
does he have the time though it's gonna
be so close absolutely faze have one map
two and they'll go up two to nothing in
this series
[Applause]
from there things looked over for g2
down two maps and a best of five they
tried to fight back but it didn't matter
there was blood in the water and faze
could taste it one second's on the clock
and g2 is being harassed every step of
the way nico doesn't have the help and
jks has a triple that shuts it all down
13 to 10. a.k.a picked back up by alex
cb but he was tagged in the process
hunter instead they'll get jks
he's still here oh they lined up he's
actually hit one plus two he did damage
that's going to drop them down hunter
and it's all over twice with the final
count and faze finally stays finally on
the stage encounter will take a
championship so many gambles on this
team but it's finally paid off the intel
extreme masters kind of into champions
phase plan at
[Applause]
that trophy marked jks's first ever
premier tournament win the first premier
tournament victory for any australian cs
go player ever and the final statement
on the single greatest stand-in
performance esports has ever seen
honestly i don't think it's really sunk
in too much yet massive thing especially
for me because uh the first time i went
to that event would have been 2015 i
think a lot of the times i was actually
watching in the crowd and stuff for me
at least i think that's my third time on
stage and then that time i actually win
it's i don't know it's
honestly pretty surreal i don't really
know how to describe it it's hard to say
where jks will end up after all this
what we can say for certain is that he's
shot himself back onto the radar of
every roster looking to round out their
ranks jks is probably the best standard
i've had he played robin's role which is
his comfort zone and then he jumped into
my role which is definitely not his
comfort zone but he played really hard
for the tournament and the results
showed but jks is determined to only
commit to the right team i want to make
sure like
i get a team
where i know i'm going to be comfortable
in like where i'm actually going to be
able to be myself and
everyone gets along with each other and
stuff like that like i want to actually
just make sure it's the right
opportunity and something that i don't
just like jump into it
because
i mean i don't think there's gonna be
that many more opportunities after the
next one honestly it doesn't really
matter what kind of offers jks gets the
man won one of the most prestigious
tournaments in cs go had his name etched
into a trophy that most pros only dream
of and he did it all when no one
expected it from him jks did the
impossible and no matter where he goes
from here
he'll always have something to show for
it
at this clear
at this point it wasn't clear what would
come next for jks what does this clear
mean when i said that what was i
thinking what was my brain doing
i know words
had this clearing i want to i know words
i have a master's degree in words how
the what the [__] am i saying